so we've come to one of the rural
villages in the African area of turkey
it's north of the epicenter but you can
see buildings here families still
affected here the whole roof has
collapsed it looks like side of the
building also has come down as well and
that's not the only problem facing
people here you can also see when we
swing round that they've lost power in
some of the places in this Village so
the power line down here but also a very
badly damaged family home there you can
see blankets popping out the side the
roof again has collapsed and then the
whole front of the building has been
totally exposed with the rubble falling
onto what is potentially the family car
and the problem for people living in
rural areas like this is firstly access
to Aid we've spoken to volunteers who've
managed to get here and they said that
no government Aid has come here yet that
the government is focusing on the cities
they have no idea when they'll come to
places like this where there are 600 odd
people living so instead volunteers are
doing what they can they're focusing on
giving people blankets because of the
bitter cold giving people toilet paper
trying to give people water as well with
the power down that's another problem as
well that families here are facing but
also if you have a look around there's
snow everywhere on the ground here we're
surrounded by mountains it's bitterly
cold minus eight at least today and so
the real Focus here is on keeping warm
so that's a massive challenge for these
communities because not only do they
have to contend with the Damage Done by
the earthquake but also for the cold
weather and keeping themselves safe
going forward